Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast and I'm checking in on Ya.
I know my voice is still fucked up.
I'll be back or maybe I shredded it
for life. What am I doing right now?
I'm sitting on a pullout couch and
what is supposed to be my office,
but no work gets done in here. Um,
yeah. I'm just fucking chilling out.
I got a little half a grapefruit
here then I'm going to eat later.
Cause all freckles is a fat
fuck and he's turning it around.
That's what I'm doing. I'm turning around.
I'm not going to try to blame Hollywood
for fucking given me an impossible body
image to live up to. I'm going
to, I'm going to use it as a goal.
All these fucking pussies out there now
a days. Whoa. That's too hard. Yeah,
it is hard. Eat An apple.
Get your fat ass at the gym.
Okay.
That's what America needs right
there. Now for this fucking,
okay.
I don't know what this patty cake,
we're plug and play with everybody.
Jesus fucking Christ. You live in a
great country. There's too many cookies.
All right? No that and leave the
house. It's all you gotta do.
Fucking sitting here blaming RBS for
your fat ass. Huh? Hating on those.
Those fucking Victoria's
secret models are, uh,
whoever the new fucking Brad Pitt guy
is with his fucking eight pack. Ah.
Oh, that's been airbrushed.
Oh fuck you. You Fat.
You ain't a big king every
fucking day for the last 20 days.
That's your problem. It's not
society. It's that you have a car.
They have a drive through and
you have singles in your wallet.
Where are you going to spend it? Drive
your fat ass down to the supermarket.
Just like my doughy midsection.
I'm bringing it down there
looking like the fucking freckled.
Imagine the Pillsbury Pillsbury
dough boy with like freckles.
That's what I'm looking right
now by my fucking shirt on.
Put on a good 12 pounds, a
writers' room weight. You know,
you know what I like to go for? I
like the Hershey's many inches, right?
Get that fucking sugar rush.
Then I'm like, Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
Then I eat a handful of fucking pretzels.
Bring me back down with the salt and
then where am I? Oh, late night. Oh,
we're working late again. Did I
all, let's get a fucking pizza.
I'm just going to have one slice,
four slices hot right
down the fucking pie hall.
And who am I blaming? Huh? My blaming
those whores on Instagram. I'm not,
not me. I'll take a responsibility
for my gluttonous acts.
I am a fucking ONA. I'm not
a mess. I'm turning around.
Okay.
Old Daddy, white legs here. Get
up to almost a buck 86 you know,
now I'm back down to a buck 82 my goal
is just to be in the one seventies but
I'm in the fucking one seventies by
the time we're done with the next two
episodes. Right? A couple, two or three
pounds of the next two weeks. Right.
I can do that shit even though
the of July is coming up. Right.
And that's the big day we celebrate
Independence Day. You know,
wasn't that the day we had the fight
with the British and we said a one if by
land two of spicy and get those
native Americans off my property.
Isn't that, isn't that what
happened on that day? Um,
we declared independence
from England on July 4th,
1776. We were like, we're
sick of you oppressing us.
We would like to be the oppresses and
it's took us almost 300 years to get there
and God dammit, what dealt with doing
it as good as England ever did it.
Take that Fuckos
um,
anyways, got to drink the throat coat tea.
I don't know why I never drank
this before. I can tell you,
you know something that's fucking
delicious as a God damn grapefruit,
not a regular grapefruit.
A goddamn grapefruit.
They're right next to the Sunkist.
You go in there, you, hey,
you got a goddamn grapefruit. I'm sorry.
We only have Sunkist and then you say,
well fuck you buddy. Fuck
you. When you create a salary.
That's what I'm back to salary at night.
My little scoop of fucking peanut,
right. I'm six months into this year.
My drinking's back under control,
not that will bring your drinking back
under control like eight fucking corona
lights that somebody left at my
fucking fridge, Jesus Christ.
But slowly knocking those things back
one a day and it's just such a horrible
experience. By the end of it, it's like
I did, not only do I not want another,
I don't think I ever want to drink
again, you know? Oh, so whatever.
So I'm only had one cigar this month,
so I've had nine for the
year, so that's good. Right?
It's going to go off the rail soon, right.
We've got 4th of July and then I got
fucking the European brand coming up,
you know, and uh,
I was on a flight and I somehow discovered
this part of Ciga affection that Oh,
um, it's places to smoke. Few like cigars,
people go on cigar affection out or.com
and you click on search cigar aficionado
oneF who know? Um, I thought it was
spelled like after with two F's.
Right? I'm kidding. I just love all the
people when I play up, how stupid I am.
They just love, you
know, you guys dominant.
You're right next to me
at the Applebee's, right?
Just order your fried
fucking pickles. You can't,
um, [inaudible]
scarf.
Actually not a oneF as in fuck
and a Google places to smoke.
I mean, it's just, it's
fucking, it's incredible. So
I've, um, I've done that all across
Europe, but I just did it like every,
like fifth city or something. So I don't
go off the rails when I'm over there.
So I've got a couple of days in
London, I'm going to smoke there,
and then I think I'm just gonna fucking
haul ass for the rest of the trip and
maybe take a few days off, a
little vacation, little holiday,
you know, somewhere down
the Mediterranean, right.
Look at all fancy freckles.
You like this? What a fucking life.
Flunked everything in high school. Huh?
You need two years of a
language. No, you don't.
You just need to be a silly comment and
have enough people get into you and all
of a sudden you too.
You too can not add up how much your
vacation costs and then get a credit card
bill. It'd be like, Ooh, what the
fuck? That's one of my favorite things.
I might sound a little more jovial
than usual. There's a reason for that.
There is a fod as a fucking reason
is the great Sam Kinison would say.
I um, I uh, I finally bought a car.
Daddy bought a whip. Oh look who's here.
The Levenia just in time for me
to talk about my new fucking car.
Let's turn up the Mike Nini.
I gotta tell you I bought,
you know when I bought yes, I
bought the BMW bitch magnet.
That's what it's called. No, I
didn't buy a BMW. I bought a Jaguar.
Um, and I ordered it.
I bought a Jag and I,
and I ordered the color cause I didn't
want to be another douche driving a
black,
white or fucking red car as
they make calls me driving a,
what does that British racing green.
Yeah, like every was supposed to be,
oh, you're hating. You hate on me
right now. It's fucking beautiful.
Cold freezing in here. You notice
that I'm wearing like, oh you're,
you're fucking Apollo 13 jacket. Yeah,
go turn off the AC bombers. Well, cause
it was, it was hot as hell on you. Oh,
okay. Yeah, I'm a white.
The cold doesn't affect me.
You know how I get on the beach and
look like I'm having heat stroke.
You're sitting there frolicking
around. Why isn't this great?
I'm under that giant fucking umbrella
looking like it was my final wish to go
to the beach for the first time ever in
my life, it of my life. Remember that guy?
Do you know what somebody
told me to buy on the, uh,
on the old inner web there? Is
Richard Wrong? He says, yeah,
downstairs saying in her webs. I love
when he says that. Why I love that guy.
Get Yourself. Because I look at him going,
he flunked everything in high
school too, and he still made it.
They put so much emphasis
on being smart in school.
You don't have to be
everything in school. What was,
when I say I flunked
everything up the ceiling,
the glass ceiling I couldn't
push through was cs.
And then there was a bunch
of ds and then just the, uh,
the math was just the old right
there, Fred. Ugh. What about,
I've never shown you my fucking,
I think I still, I have this desk,
my parents don't throw anything
out. It's still in there.
And every once in a while there's
this little thing and I open it up to,
oh my God. Really? Oh, I
was showing you all my,
my achievements certificates.
Yeah. Oh, opposites attract Neil.
But it's like a, it's a
bunch of C's and easiest.
It's like English and stuff
like that. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
I stopped going. I stopped
getting A's and B's. Right.
I did well until through junior high.
And then when it counted
when the fucking colleges were
gonna have to do more than share,
the greatest thing,
the greatest thing I ever
did was completely fuck up
in high school because why?
Because of I did well, if I
did well and I lived the dream
like,
and I w I got accepted into a big time
college that had a great fucking football
program and I joined a Frat and I had
penny loafers with no socks on and all
that. Just live in the white guy dream.
We definitely wouldn't
be right if I did that.
Like I,
I just think I would have been doing
so well in life that getting into this
business never would have dawned
on me. I would've been like, well,
I can't leave. Right. I'm
driving a convertible Audi.
I got a, I got the extra special cubicle
and I don't think I would've done it,
but the fact that I fucked up so bad that
my options were only going part time,
two low level schools and unloading trucks
that then going and doing an open mic
that wasn't as scary. Like what was
I walking away from? That's true.
Lower back pain. I mean, look at me
now. I Erica, I think it's curious. Um,
penny loafers with no socks. I feel
like that's a big red flag to me.
Like there's just something
about it that I just, yeah,
it's like when black people
weren't loafers with no socks.
That's like on w certain white
people see black guys in hoodies.
It's the same thing. Yeah,
it is. I said, well, no,
it isn't because of the power
structure, but it's the same thing.
You're totally looking at him.
You look at those penny loafers with
no socks and you're like, frat boy,
date rapists. Yeah, it's true.
We agreed to have aggressive sex and
you end up face down dead in a park.
Yeah, exactly. Yes. You're
allowed to say that, right? Yeah.
Okay. I'm not allowed to say that.
I'm not allowed to see a black
guy with a Hoodie at 12 midnight.
It's we'll be like, oh,
he's working on an app and he just
came outside to stretch his legs.
Then I ended up in a trunk
of a car. Ah. But I do.
I do feel that way and I know that that's
a stereotype and I know that that's
wrong. Why do you have yes. Yeah. Well,
you know, it's, if I think about like,
why do you have like
Kennedy's and you have like,
you have this Trump white
eyeliner on here. Oh No.
I think that's my eye cream that I
didn't fully blended my skin. Oh God.
You're spoiled. I'm not spoiled.
I think that's my ice cream.
I put it on at night. I have a
promoter that's a bad stereotype.
What is preppy guys?
Preppy white guys or serial
killers are date rapists.
But I feel like if they were to
be, they would get away with it.
Good. I just feel like it's a safe
thought is money. It's a safe thought.
The think is a woman [inaudible]
just go with the bad.
So you get home in one piece? Yeah. If
you think somebody is going to eat you,
you, you got to go with
that thought. Yeah.
And just just avoid regardless of how
many people's feelings you hurt. Right.
But like I get just people wearing like,
so how do you think white
people should handle pants?
How do you think white people
should handle the other situation?
And like boat shoes and like blazers
or like shorts with whales on them.
Then you got you gotta you fucking got
this person down or like their hair is so
perfect and they've got their
like color pop, just so on.
They're like Ralph Lauren,
like yellow, buttoned down.
You've got issues with salmon shorts
and like a white belt with a blue stripe
down the middle of it.
So what if a guy like that came walking
up to you and started talking to you in
the club? I would feel very only, what
is your name? Is it something ethnic?
My name is Scott [inaudible].
Scott. Uh, no,
I'm being very stereotypical right now.
There are plenty of those guys that are
a part of the yacht club and the golf
and glove and, um, are they're lovely
people. Where did you meet those people?
I've never been, I'm really white. I've
never met those people. I've just, yeah,
I'm, I'm being, I'm being
stereotypical and it's wrong.
Do you know one time I met he
wasn't, he wasn't like a waspy guy.
He was a Jewish guy. Right.
And I was at this wedding for buddy
of mine who was Jewish. Right?
So I was like one of
the only gentiles there,
and eight I had just moved to fucking
Manhattan and this guy fucking big lead to
me big time. Right?
I was living on this out
walkthrough bedroom on 97 east,
97th street. Right. And, uh, you know,
crack heads smoking underneath the
thing, the total New York experience.
Like the first night I'm laying
in my single bed, you know,
just just like a little kid bed and a
like a roach walked across my chest that
night and I just thought that was
part of, I didn't even kill it.
I just thought it was part of the
New York experience. I was like,
all right man, I need to get tough.
So I was like, fuck it. Alright,
bugs are gonna crawl on me. I can take
this shit. Right. So I go to the uh,
but I was still excited. Oh, it's such
a German, Irish toughy. Fucking dope.
You guys will put up with any
yup. And that's why we die young.
That's all we die young. One day I'll
let it all out and I'll do that epic cry.
Like that black dude on the intervention.
Cause I still do and I'll be like
[inaudible]
when you watched that yesterday,
the cry of man who hasn't cried
and like ever who was a baby,
we watched that yesterday in the writer's
room and then we watch one of the
worst ones ever because I love the Guy
Mike Schmidt retiring from baseball.
We watched that one and it's such a shame
the amount of shit that that guy gets.
Cause he could literally
at this still at this age,
he could literally pick me up and throw
me out of the major league in field.
I would land shallow left, but he
just goes like, you know, whatever.
Like I forget how it whip. It was like
20 years ago a boy left, blah, blah,
blah, Wisconsin. Where did the hell he
was with the dream to play originally.
He went all the way. I was like,
oh no. So somebody had that video,
major league and then they
immediately cut to the black. I got,
ah dude, we fucking died. We fucking died.
And I was actually sitting there
when I was [inaudible] watching that.
How hard we were all laughing.
I was wishing I could reach out to the
person that made that cause I would be
psyched, you know,
if I wasn't in this business and a bunch
of people in a writer's room right now
on a fucking show, like we don't laugh
at Shit, dude, we will fucking dying.
So I mean, I wish my standup got that
kind of fucking left in my writer's room.
That's all right. What's the setup as
a tracking and all of that shit. So,
um, anyways. Um,
all right. So where are we now?
Where are we talking about?
We were talking about your car.
Oh yeah. Your Jaguar. Jaguar.
So like about the Jaguar, the
Jaguar. DXF Are you excited for,
I'm so fucking excited. I'm not
excited that it doesn't come for,
it's 100 days away.
That's what happens when you order a
custom color countdown every single day.
Yeah. If you don't mind,
can I be excited about this?
I drove a fucking Prius for
nine years. You're right. Yeah.
I've been gay bashed for the better
part of a decade. Driving that car. Yes.
Long overdue. I can tell you that's
a hot fucking car though. The Prius.
I've had two people already
offered to buy it. Can I buy it?
Can I buy it off here? I know that
car is done right by us. Yes it is.
Although it smells,
you got a detailed that one time and then
we came home and it was a hot day and
the windows were up in
whatever that chemical was.
Did they put in the seat if fucking
baked in there and like, yeah,
know how to get it out? Yeah.
It's like somebody died in
there that cleans houses. No,
it doesn't smell like somebody
died in there. It's this, this got,
you know a certain, yeah,
you have to eat something and you kind
of think you like it and then there's yet
weird after taste and you're like, Whoa,
we can't sell it until we figure
out how to get rid of that.
You need to learn to talk into the
mic. There you go. Not to. Okay.
You know what they're not. They'll just
pick a height. Can hear me. All right,
I'm going to turn you up a mile away. I'm
sorry. It's because of you. Hey,
I don't like that or that Remy Ma just
cause she shot somebody that's fucking
great. So many people in that genre
act like they would do shit like that.
But at the end of the day, like what
am I a fucking, I got a Bentley.
I don't need to be shooting people. Yeah.
She actually shot somebody
and she went to jail for it.
I don't think she's like proud of it by
any means, but, well no. You know what?
I know I had to see her out and do it.
I'm not advocating shooting people.
What I'm saying, what's cool is that
if she talks about shit like that,
you know that she's not pretending.
Oh, I certainly wouldn't fuck with her.
Yeah. Like I'm still waiting for
Robert Blake to put out an album.
You know he fucking flake.
Yeah, he plays guitar. Wait,
he's not dead. No, he's out.
I went into a guitar shop one time
and he was in there. No. Yeah,
I would run the other way. He's so scary.
Don't go to bed with the
price on your head. No.
So you enjoy, you enjoyed
watching the bet awards with me.
I did the whole prince tribute and
all that. It was fucking tremendous.
Fucking tremendous. I don't know why
you guys were upset about the Oscars.
You guys have a better award show.
Just do one yourself and
show us how to do a good one.
I don't know why the fuck
you're trying to get there.
Yeah. Our shows generally
seem to be more fun,
but oh Jesus. Where the
hell is on you? No, no.
It's not more or less fun. It's just
you're going to be able to be yourselves.
I don't know who that is. I
Dunno what the fuck happened.
All of a sudden I got on this list like
congratulations your businesses one and
just hang up. What kills me is they
keep calling, which means somebody out.
It's enough people at works on.
There's enough people that sit there.
Congratulations. Like holy
Shit Allen. Get it here. Eight,
four, four number. Cause I
have some weird eight, four,
four number that keeps
calling me and it's business,
but you know they have those
machines that like this.
Try every single combination of phone
numbers and whatever one hits and someone
picks up, they're like, hello,
I have some exciting news for you. Yeah,
it's not exciting. It's fucking annoying.
You know what the worst is when I'm out
walking Cleo and I'm listening to some
song, right? I'm listening
to some songs, so of course,
any song that I listened to,
I am on stage with the band playing
drums and I'm killing it and they're all
turning around and
looking at me like, wow,
this guy has more skills than we thought.
That's what I do with the entire time
I'm out there fantasize and then all of a
sudden the phone comes on and I'm
old. Whenever it's a random number,
I just think at some radio
station that I used to do,
and that's always good for business. I
pick up the phone, I make people laugh,
drive time, you know, whatever.
I'm not even in the city and
they're hearing me make them laugh.
Maybe they'll come out to a show.
So I always pick up and I'll be
like in the middle of a, what was,
I was listening to Queens of the stone
age today. I'll listen to them. And, uh,
ozone gay man ain't gay, Gay, Gay,
da Da da and nicotine and get up like
a day or extra speed. Whoa, whoa.
Okay. Okay. But it, yeah, I'm
just fucking listening to it.
Of course I'm on the drums going gay,
gay, gay, gay, gay, gay, gay kid, right.
Fucking kill it, Josh. Turnaround
Code. Wow. Right. Totally impressed.
Which will never happen.
Right? So I can dream.
And then the fucking photo
rank. He's impressed with you,
but not for your musical skills.
I know he's not impressed with me.
Why would you say that and ruin
this great story. He fucking, uh,
so I'm walking down the street and the
fucking phone rings and then I stopped
listening to that and I fucking, uh, I
pick up, it was like, congratulations.
Your fantasy as over a year, your best,
this letter won a free trip to a room.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
So even if you know you
don't have a radio station,
you'll just still pick
up random numbers. Yeah.
You have to stop doing that also. Why
wouldn't you? Hey, do you a thank you.
Do you ever think he ever like dialed
somebody? Dial the number incorrectly?
Well, I guess you don't
do it that much anymore,
but every once in a while you just fucking
dial a number. You'd dial it wrong.
You ever think he actually like called
somebody famous? Like they have phones,
they got to get wrong numbers.
They don't pick up numbers that
they don't recognize. Yeah, they do.
You don't think Jay Lo picks up. It's
like, oh, whatever. She sounds like what?
She goes, I'm just, I'm
just chatting on the Bronx.
I don't know what the fuck she said.
You wouldn't pick up like Bill Clinton.
I don't understand. I Bet Bill Clinton
picks up random numbers. Oh, of course.
Yeah. You know, he does. He's
like, hmm. Oh, could this be,
I dunno what now he's looking
like very frail. Uh, yeah,
he's old and Vegan now,
so I feel like that is that why he looks
like a scarecrow that came to life.
If a scare crow fucked a snowman
for scarecrow, fuck the snow man.
That's what he looks like cause he's
keeps his pasty as a snowman and his
skinny. I've never felt more alive.
He comes at you with that
fucking chicken neck. Um,
can we talk about how you kind of like
to like in the same vein as you picking
up numbers and being like, yeah, sure.
How you just don't pay attention.
What stuff?
Like what happened when I asked you
to get minute rice and grapefruit.
What did you bring home?
A cantaloupe and a regular
rice that took 20 minutes.
I thought Uncle Ben's was always minute
rice. He thought he had shit the dope.
I was wrong. Ben Can hang around. Hmm.
Came on with the cantaloupe. What do you
want from me? It was delicious though,
wasn't it? It was,
but I just feel like you've just get a
vague idea of like what's supposed to
happen and just kind of run
with it. Like you're like, oh,
that's around melon fruit or
something. Not even a melon.
You weren't even supposed to get a Mellon.
Just you just knew it was round and it
was probably next to the grapefruit and
you just grabbed it not thinking, yeah,
you want to do, you know it's
sure. Alright, so I bought
you a nice fucking car,
right? And you park and under a
tree. So I got this fucking the top,
the tarp that fits your car like a
fucking glove and you're not putting it on
and the fucking saps coming down on
your car. So I sit there and go near.
Why don't you put the
top on the car and like,
is there anyway somebody can
turn back the tree? It's like,
or you could just put the
fucking tarp on the car. I know,
but I also feel like that she
needs to be cut back in general.
Why that tree is right out
side can hear you right now.
Don't worry buddy,
you're not going anywhere because it's
just trapping those weird things all over
the place. It's called nature
called nature. Nia. We live.
We shouldn't even be out here.
That tree should be out here. Okay.
I'm not saying that you should cut it
down and like it should be just cut it
back.
That's all I'm saying is cut it back
or maybe like cut it so that it grows.
Why don't you just put the
fucking tarp on the car?
I have a problem putting a
tarp, the tarp on the car.
Then there you go with salt.
Yeah you do have a problem.
Cause I went down there,
there was shit all over your car and
I'm telling you the fucking last night.
And what happens is a lot
of people don't know this.
I learned this the hard
way. What happens is,
and I'm explaining this and I
know you don't like this, but I'm,
I explaining when the fucking
PSAP gets on your fucking car,
you gotta end up not talking
to you. You got to get it off.
Cause what happens is
when your car heats up,
the paint expands and then
at night when it cools off,
it contracts again and
it's like a motion, right?
The SAP and the paint become one.
It's like a tattoo and then
it's underneath your fucking
paint and you can't get
it up. At least that's what the guy at
the car wash told me. Cause I was like,
Hey, what about these spots here? And
he's like, oh my friend, my friend.
We're not friends. Tell me what happened.
So I like your blue dress.
Thank you. I got it yesterday.
What'd you get it? Top shop. Top
Shop? Yes. Is that expensive?
No, I'm actually good. Good
Job Nini. Get a red one too.
I like topshop. The money morning
podcast sponsored by topshop.
Topshop. That'd be great. Well Youtube,
why? Cause they'd send me some dresses.
Yeah, yeah, that fit me. Ideally
I'm the host. I get the dresses.
So you excited about the a Austrian
Grand Prix on Sunday? Yeah.
You know what? All you need to
go is to one of those races.
Once you see the fucking the WHO has
at that fucking thing, the money,
I should say, oh, we're going to go to
the Grand Prix and Mako at some point.
Oh, I'd love to. I'd love to. And just
go there like no is a dumb American.
Just annoy all this rich people.
All right. I gotta read here
a little bit of a Oh yeah,
that one somebody had on yesterday a
had the American flag back to back world
war champs. You got to wear
that over in Europe. Oh my God.
They would just crunch it.
There's nothing better than just
playing into who they think you are. Um,
anyways, here we go. Loot crate everybody.
Give me the loop with Luke crate,
you get collectibles apparel and more
from your favorite pop culture franchise
delivered right to your door.
Every single month we're talking
to new tee shirt in every crate,
figures, comics and
stuff for your kitchen.
Oh this is this comic con
shit near a wide range of x.
You can have like an Aquaman's Spatula,
you know I Spiderman Jug of milk,
you know Robin Pajama Bottoms, you know,
and then Batman on top cause he's
definitely is again that they, sorry,
I'm sorry.
We're talking a new t shirt and I went
out a ride range of exclusive items you
can't get anywhere else from a fan.
Favorite franchise like Harry Potter,
Marvel Comics fall out for fuck was I
when the first three came on star wars and
so much more of what is fallout for
is that a band you're thinking you're
thinking fall out boy or some 41 and you
can get all of this for less than $20 a
month. Matchbox 20 member
everything at a number look,
loot crate come geek out with us.
Luke Craig is a monthly subscription box
service for epic Geek and Gamer items
and pop culture gear for
less than $20 a month.
He gets 68 items that include licensed
gear, parable, collectibles, unique,
one of a kind items and more.
This is going to be fucking huge.
People love this shit.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM
Pacific time to subscribe and receive this
month crate and when the cutoff
happens, that's it. It's over.
Make sure to head to
www.lukecrate.com/burr and enter code
bird to save $3 on any subscription that
you go. Oh my God, Nia, we
got to talk sports here. Oh,
should I leave? No. You know what?
Yes. Just the way you just said that
[inaudible] and you're
looking at your phone.
You have Kardashians tone right now
and it's really, oh my God, I'm not,
I just had a bath. I just, you know,
I don't know anything about sports.
So call me when we know a little bit.
Can you believe PK Suba and
got traded for Shea? Well, Oh,
I know that you are.
Just couldn't stop talking about
it this morning while we were,
I couldn't believe it. I
thought he was a hab full life.
I fucking hate when
that happens. You know,
Joe Barton had talked me off the ledge.
He said fucking Nashville needed a staff
and something about the habs needed to
be a little more solid and tougher
on defense is some shit like that.
So I guess it's a good trade.
Who the fuck knows? But, uh,
I hate when big stars like
that. That's why I was like,
Steven Stamkos resigned with
Tampa. Like, you know, he's, he's,
he's like, and he's, I can't say a
lightning. It's such a stupid fucking,
I hate when they named teams after
weather, whatever, pks a hat, man,
that's fucked up. Even as a Bruins Fan,
I'm going to miss like a, you know,
I never really hated the guy. These one
of those guys. He was so fucking good.
You couldn't hate him. You know what
I mean? The Montreal Canadian fans,
however, you know, with this silly socks
and little pockets squeezed in. Yeah.
Um, all right. I gotta wrap this
thing up cause I have to go, uh,
we're doing the record for, uh,
actually still number eight.
We're writing number nine. Everybody,
I'm coming out the fucking,
what's that thing that comes out?
The Golfer, right? Groundhog.
Groundhog pokes his fucking head out.
Keep much of my head came out. I mean,
how many more fucking weeks of
winter would that be? Um, all right,
that's 30 minutes. It's
going to be a long winter
and I'll never forget 2016
when the round is white.
His head ever came out of that hole
and an email about a seven night
Mediterranean cruise riding from
Venice starting at eight 99.
But I don't think that's the kind of thing
that we underneath the boat or we set
the refugee special.
I think that's the kind of thing where
it's like we have to work on the boat
when we go there and like 4,000 other
people at the, at the buffet line.
Oh yeah. You can't even
get a cruise for that.
There's no fucking way you're getting
on this. What does the boat look like?
I don't know. It's a dinghy. Yeah. All
right. Well I don't know. I'll have to,
I'll have to do something evil
to ever be able to afford that,
but it's nice to notice. Um,
all right. That's it. Ah,
that's the a Thursday afternoon
podcast for um, wait a minute.
What not and yeah, to go to
work. I totaled the pyramid game.
That's the only reason why. Oh fuck.
All right. Let's Do the pyramid game.
All right. Where are we? I
don't want to make you late.
Should we save it for now? Let's do
it. I said, so we want to do it next.
Monday's a holiday.
Are you going to do as it are you going
to do a podcast on the 4th of July?
Yeah, of course. No days off. Yeah.
This is how much fun this fucking is.
Okay. So I fuck around the advertising.
I don't give a shit if they're here or
not. I'm still going to do it. All right,
so those of you who weren't listening
the past week, I got fucking a,
what do you say there? Uh, what did
we do that, that $10,000 pyramid,
it all came about because we were talking
about how you just notoriously, uh,
sort of just gets things wrong or
it was really more about how your,
your movie titles, that's how
it started. Yeah. You know,
I danced around the last days of
Dracula set of same Pearl Jam.
I'd be like a flannel
shirt. Oh, I'm in a trance.
This music's making me go crazy.
I don't like George Bush. Exactly.
But I knew that one. That's
any better. Yeah. So then
we started playing the
pyramid game. All right.
So evidently I sucked at giving clues.
Let's see if you're better. All right,
you ready? Oh wait, so I'm
going first. No, it's your turn.
I gave last time. You received
like I thought I also gave,
I thought we both know. No, we did.
We both did. No, it doesn't matter.
But now you do. Do you have them
in your head? Uh, I'll, you stink.
He was supposed to make a list. I know
what's in it for next time then. No,
you can't do that to people.
Well, I'm sorry people. Well,
I'm going to hit pause. You're
going to do it right now. All right.
They're going to be easy. All right, we're
back. She said they're going to beat.
Don't make them easy. It's
three. Okay, here we go.
And let's get the clock going
here. All right. And Go.
So, uh, Michael Jordan has won a ring.
Steph curry mistress. I think
that secretary has one of the,
people think they're ugly.
I'm sure Lebron has haircut
sneakers makers. Okay. Um,
they're not native to California, but
they're everywhere. They Avocados,
they provide shade people, real
housewives, them real housewives.
All fake Tammy victims. They're
natural palm trees. Yes. Bam.
Um, 4th of July celebration at
Fox heart attacks. They're in the
fireworks. Yeah, I'll come
on. That was a joke. No,
I was too easy then. You know what? You
just made me feel like I was special.
Come up. Think of a
difficult one right now.
Some obscure so I can guess.
Okay, you got it. All right,
and three a two a one. They're a big,
huge animal. That's bad. When you think
Cheetah, they're in the water catch.
They're vicious. SCO Sharks, a Barracuda,
whales sweat. They're, they can run fast.
They're in the water and they can run
fast frogs. They're very plant a Pulitzer.
This is,
and they attack you Barracuda there in
an iPhone commercial and it says at the
end, not on an iPhone. Can you
hear me now they were a game,
a game from the Sapa leaf seventies
and eighties getting more eighties,
there was a bunch of m and a ring jaws
and they had the eats and like you and
your song animal and the water,
a big fat animal, a whale,
a walrus sale.
And in the game there was
four of them in each corner.
And you and your friends like hit it and
they had the like, Oh I hit ball. Yes.
God thought you meant the ocean. Ah, fuck.
That's only like three minutes to get,
you should have said that. Hungry,
hungry. Cause I didn't want it
to be too easy. Oh, there you go.
I could have done better. No, that
was good. See you make them hard.
They make them hard then it's done the
bit last longer. Make it easy. I'm easy.
See I'm you open when
it rains umbrella. Okay.
All right. I have to go.
All right. 100 more days
counting down. That's right.
Can't wait. All right, a,
that's the Thursday afternoon podcast.
Enjoy the music that's coming up.
Have a great July 4th weekend. Uh,
thank you to everybody in this country
that's come out to my shows and thank you
to England for losing that great
battle today on uh, July 4th.
Right. Then they lose a battle
and we signed a paper like, ah,
you motherfuckers, we
got, you know, I know,
I know what it is. We
declared over into foot.
I just like doing it
because it makes them feel
and that's right where you want to just
coming in. What do they call themselves?
Cozy, smug counts. And then you give him
the old right there, Fred. All right,
that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
Have a wonderful weekend and
I'll talk to you on Monday there.
[inaudible]
hey.
Oh, okay.
[inaudible] oh
[inaudible].
Hey, what's going on? It's bill births.
The Monday morning podcast
for what the Hell is today?
June 29th June 30th fuck is a date.
I don't know. I don't know where it is.
The last Monday in June and I can't
believe how much the summer is just flying
by Jay. When somebody say say
that every fucking summer,
you know,
you know what's going to fly by because
the weather is awesome cause it's fun.
It's like eating cookies,
you know, you open a bag,
you think you're just going to have one.
Next thing you know the whole
bag's gone. You know why?
Because they taste delicious too.
You really need some douchebag
to stand there next to you.
The one like couldn't your blue
how good those cookies were.
I can't believe they're already gone. Um,
I wish someone would
say that in the winter.
Can you believe how fast
the winter's going by?
What kind of person would say that? Huh?
Some sort of mountain man who's into
snowboarding. Alright. That was awesome.
I don't fucking, alright, it's the
Monday morning, but Monday, June 30th.
Sorry. I'll, okay.
I was riffing and I was looking
up with the date was all right.
As I've told you guys in past podcasts,
I have one of the oldest still
functioning laptops out there.
I told you mine is actually
made out of Birch. I, uh,
I got it down at the, uh, pottery barn
back when they used to sell laptops.
A lot of people don't know that.
They think that they were, uh,
just into furniture. But there was
a moment there where they'd stay,
tried to branch out into computers and
electronics and needless to say fail.
And, uh, actually, you know what I was
thinking about getting a new laptop, but,
um, good friend of mine told me how
to, what? Add more memory to this one.
So I'm thinking, why the fuck? Why
would I go out and get a new one?
I don't understand why people keep
going out and buying new laptops.
Like they're fucking Steven Spielberg
and they're dumping like hours of film
footage. You're not doing it. Okay.
They cost like two, three fucking
grand. What are you doing?
You know what I mean?
Do you ever just stop and think
what the fuck you're doing?
Just get off the Goddamn fucking hamster
wheel for a second and just realize how
ridiculous it is that you spent $2,500
on something and it's acceptable that the
thing is going to shit the bed within
fucking two years been two years,
something's going to happen.
You know the battery's gonna mess up and
then you're going to go down to the Mac
store or the fucking Bill Gates store,
whatever the hell they got out there.
And they going to be like, yeah,
um, it's not under warranty. Uh,
can we fix the year? We can fix it. Book.
Oh to fix it for some stupid
fucking reason is gonna
Cause 2100 and a new app up
is 25. So, you know, I mean, we'll fix it,
but you know, the whole
thing is fucking bullshit.
There's no reason they should cost that
much. You know, you know something,
if nerds had any fucking brains,
the amount of pussy they
would be getting right now
just by fixing their friends,
laptops and saving everybody 2,500
bucks instead of charging people 1800,
why don't you charge charge like
500 bucks? You fucking nerds go out,
you know, buy something flashy that
always attracts the horse. They like that,
you know? No. Just to give yourself
a little makeover with the, with the,
with your laptop fixing
abilities, money, you know,
like one of those bad eighties movies,
you can turn your life into
like a montage, you know,
play some songs like the fine young
cannibals as some chick takes you to the
mall, you know, takes off your glasses.
I always hated that in those fucking
movies. Like whenever like somebody,
you know, whenever they
were going to have like, uh,
like the nerdy Chicco all of a
sudden become gorgeous. Right?
Like the way they made her ugly was they
put her hair up and they made her wear
black frame glasses. You know what I mean?
Like you still couldn't see
that she was gorgeous, you know?
And then they just take her hair down
and then she take off her glasses and
everybody's like, oh my
God, who is that? You know?
And then the date rape is football player
comes up to her and then she always
like a, it's like, no, I
don't think so. You know,
you didn't like me when I,
when I had my hair up and I was
wearing these glasses. Okay.
But this nerd over here,
he always liked me.
So now we're going to go to the prom and
we're going to dance and that's going
to be the end of the fucking movie. Okay.
And I always hated that moment in the
movie cause it always reminded me that I
was watching a movie because
in real life, okay, that girl,
as much as she liked the nerd, she
wouldn't like him in that way. Okay.
They can't help it send that fucking DNA.
They want to breathe with the
strongest cock in the room.
And I don't care how much of a Dick,
that guy that quarterback was being toward
the second she got the attention that
that would fill her up because all those
years they have in her hair up wearing
those fucking Malcolm x glasses
gave her low self esteem. And uh,
she,
she would at least for a four to six
year period would have to go out and
instill herself up with, please
accept me cock. You know,
before she kind of was able to
regroup and be like, you know what,
these guys are assholes. I
wonder what that nerds up to.
And by then it'll be too late
because a nerds generally, you know,
they married the first thing that a
lot of, let them fuck them, you know,
so by the time she, she, you
know, she runs through, you know,
the time she's down to
fucking the place kicker.
That nerd is already married with
three kids and he invented a,
invented the iPhone. Wait a
minute. No, he's t's fucking event.
These damn laptops, they've got it.
That's got to get repaired every couple
of years. That's their fucking payback.
Wow. I just figured that out.
That's why there's no god damn nerds out
there being able to fix these fucking
laptops for 500 bucks.
That's all 1800 bucks.
Because in math that when they gave
the fucking nerdy chicken make over,
she still blew the quarterback.
So now, now we gotta pay for it.
Ridiculous man. All right. This is
the Monday morning podcast and uh,
my name is bill burns. I do one of these
every fucking Monday. And uh, you know,
give you some laugh
about and uh, you know,
keep you in my thoughts. Actually
keep me in your thoughts.
That's why I'm doing this.
I'm not doing it cause I
give a fuck about you people.
I'm trying to give you guys a reason to
keep coming back to my site and maybe
you'll tell other people to come to my
sites and the next time we go to Raleigh,
North Carolina, I'm not standing
in front of 25 people, you know,
so then I can make some more money
and then I can buy some shiny shit.
And then I can make up for the
fall, all the fucking pussy.
I never gotten high school,
see how that works. So anyways,
I do one of these every week I talk
about stuff that I have coming up in my
career.
I talk about a comedy
date and a, you know,
whatever like is a great
example for you. I have a,
an upcoming CD DVD release.
I just like saying that CD,
DVD release, um, and a one hour, um,
comedy central special
and that will be shown,
I believe it's August 23rd. Um,
it will be shown the first time
CD's coming out in August. CV.
I don't have an exact date yet. And
the DVD is coming out in September.
I don't have an exact date for that. I
just have a month at this point. Okay.
So cool. You fucking jets. All
right. We got July 4th coming up.
Just relax. There's plenty of holidays
between now and the goddamn release.
And when I get the information, I'm
going to let you know what's up.
So that's what I have coming up. Okay.
It's gotta be in a container in that.
So let me try it. Let me, let me try to
say it a little more clearer. In August,
I have a CD coming out and a one
hour comedy central, uh, special.
Um, and in, in, uh, September,
the DVD is coming out.
So a by October you guys should
all be sick of me, but by then, uh,
hopefully I'll be filthy, stinking
rich. I'll have a brand new,
a Ludwig drum kit and a big
house and I'll stand up there,
you know,
naked with the bathrobe that's partially
opened looking down on the city,
realizing that I'm still
empty inside. Okay.
But we're going to cross that bridge
when we get to it, ma'am. All right. Um,
people ask me questions every week on
my podcast and I like to try to answer
them. People also send me in
stories. They give me information.
What do you want to start with first?
You want to start with the questions?
You want to go with the stories? How
about a story? Let me scroll down here.
Okay. Last week, you know,
people were talking about
their cars getting fucked
up and everything like that.
God Damn. And somebody sent me a funny
one and I forgot to copy and paste it.
I gotta read that one next week,
but I told you last week I was
going to tell you the second half,
basically everyone was telling me these
stories about how their car got fucked
up and then everybody's
story. They would the victim,
except for this one dude who talks
about how he was hitting on some fucking
chick and she doesn't
want to hook up with them.
So he goes out in the parking lot,
hammered and backs his car into another
truck. And I was trying to tell him,
you know, you're not
really the victim there,
so it's Kinda hard to feel bad for you.
So what the fuck did the girl do
that made you do something like that?
That we should all feel bad for you?
Me and my 14 podcast listeners should
feel bad for you. So yeah, he goes this,
this is the other half. This is his
reason for doing that shit. Uh, okay.
Hey Bill, thanks for reading my story.
Share my gloom with everyone. Ha Ha.
Let me tell you what happened
with girl number one. All right?
This is why he got, he
got pissed in the club,
was a little tipsy drunk gun in
his car, evidently did not look
stomped on the gas and
backed into a truck,
fucked his car up and didn't do shit
to the truck. All right. He said, uh,
all right. Me and the girl,
we've been working together for about a
year now and everyone in this building
would like to get with her.
We've been on and off
talking a lot or not at all.
It's a big company. She's kind of
a teeth. She's kind of a tease.
Okay, well, you know, I'm
going to take your word for it,
but I mean it kind of sounds like
she's a good looking woman. You know,
who's got a lot of caulk
coming at her and uh, you know,
maybe she's a little defensive. Um,
anyways, she kind of a tease, but hell,
I don't care. She's damn hot and I
haven't sealed the deal yet. All right,
now I'm rooting for you. That's right.
Go in and fucking hit it. All right.
I was damn sure that
this was the night. Um,
I was going to hook up with it cause we
were hanging out and talking a lot for
the few weeks leading up to
this particular night out
since it was her birthday.
Okay. So here he is, you know,
chat her up for two weeks.
He's going in the patient room as opposed
to those other guys who are walking
into the cubicle with their pants
already have on zip. You know,
I respected, everybody likes
a full court press, but uh,
that usually doesn't work, especially if
you weren't dockers. It's just creepy.
So anyway, so this guy, you
know, works if the two weeks,
now it's your birthday.
Okay. And uh, let's see.
And apparently most girls like to get
down on the day when the clock rolls over.
Okay, I'm with you anyway.
I completely fumbled the ball by not
paying enough attention or not flirting
enough that night or some shit.
And I got pissed when I knew that this
was probably the last chance I had,
which then led to the affirmation story.
So basically you did two weeks of
reconnaissance, you went out there,
it was her birthday,
and you're trying to hit
on her to close the deal.
And basically every other hot chick
that walks by and you're looking at him,
you know what,
there's not one person in their early
twenties that does not have that fucking
story that it's just what it
is. It's just pussy as to,
it's still too amazing for you with the,
you're in your thirties you'll be able
to block out the other shit and you'll be
able to focus on your target. And uh,
of course by then you'll be in your
thirties. So you'll be hitting on some,
a cougar as they say. I
hate that fucking word.
And I hate those broads who think they're
still fucking hot. Like they're 22.
Okay. I'm not saying that
hot for a 43 year old,
but we estopped wearing shit that 22 year
old chicks wear. You know what I mean?
I just turned 40. Okay. My
days of wearing a hap shirt
and fucking socks up to my knees, like
I'm in that movie dazed and confused.
You know what I mean? You'd look at me
like I was a retard. All right, stop it.
You're hot fee or age, you
look good for your age. Okay.
But let's leave it at
that. Okay. Let's, uh,
you're in your dressing elegant years.
You're in your address. Classy. Okay.
You know, once you past
fucking, you know, I dunno,
somewhere in your mid thirties if you're
still dressing like a Jello shot girl,
I don't know what to tell you.
You know what that's like.
That's like the fucking, the former
muscle head who stopped working out,
but he still has the whole
cog Hogan Wardrobe, you know,
so we still got on the tank tops,
but now he's got those flabby grandmother
arms and it's just like, dude,
you need to get a full shirt or
start doing some curls because yeah,
it's not working.
It was like Billy Crystal's grandmother
and a Mr Saturday night number.
Then they were making sandwiches out of
the arm, the fat on the back of her arm.
Um, all right. So anyway, so what did,
so you got pissed because you weren't
able to close the deals and you backed up
and smashed your car. That's
actually fucking hilarious. Um,
that's a whole different segment because
stories I was trying to get people to
tell is, you know,
you went into go buy some
a face moisturizer and you
came out and your bumper
was gone. You know, the whole,
I didn't do shit and uh,
somebody raped me stories. Um hmm.
I guess you created a new one.
People will fuck up their car cause a,
they were trying to fuck the hot chicken
work on her birthday. Okay. And uh,
I don't know. They looked at some of
the chicken. I don't know what happened.
Anyways, whatever man to man, I
feel bad for you. Okay. Is, uh,
last story I'm going to read here.
Um, all right, bill a, your Ranson.
American Airlines ring true as they
screwed a marine I met while on vacation.
I don't know if you guys
listen to this shit every week,
but American Airlines
fucked me over awhile.
Back to the point I did a puff
daddy a remix of their song.
Um, when little stop
like this wave up man,
fucking you. What?
In the aish ass h so you
can still get it on the air.
All right, so this is, this is
this guy's story. All right.
While returning from Mexico,
I was in DFW airport.
I love when people write their DFW.
Like I know what the fuck that means.
Is that Detroit fucking where
port. Oh, Dallas. Dallas.
Dallas. Fort Worth. There
we go. The Delaware.
All right. I don't know. Um,
Detroit fucking, I dunno.
I went in with the fucking guy
is, he's at DFW airport. Okay.
And I know for all you pilots out
there, hey, people do flown into lax.
Kelly x is actually a great JFK lax.
People know that. But stop saying DFW.
Like I know where the fuck that is. All
right. I was in DFW airport and I left,
said no voc. I'm in the OCC. Barely.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
Orange County, I still don't know what
that is. It's south of Los Angeles.
Thank you. Thank you.
You mean that place that nobody fucking
goes to in between Los Angeles and San
Diego. All right. I was in DFW airport
and met this guy at the tram. Oh,
just fucked it up. That word
just makes my skin crawl.
All the airports I've been,
I was at the tram. Uh,
I met this guy at the tram who was
fuming mad. He told me he was headed to,
to Gulfport,
Mississippi from California and the plane
had engine trouble and had to return.
He then caught the next flight and
then had to land in Dallas due to bad
weather.
He was then told that all all flights
out were on standby and while talking to
the gate agent, the employee got pissy
with them. What a fucking surprise.
He mentioned that he had orders and
needed help getting any flight out and the
clerk said, sir, I can't help you.
Please enjoy your night in the airport.
After the marine calmed down, I asked
him what airline he was on. He replied,
motherfucking air, American
Airlines, they suck.
I hope they go under Jesus
Christ. They even fuck over a guy.
Was He in uniform? Sharing can help you.
Please enjoy your night in the airport.
Really, please enjoy this fucking
Timberland T. I already said the c
word enough in this God damn thing.
It's ridiculous. Do you know something?
You know, just go on their website.
Just start complaining. I'm really trying
to do that shit. You know what I mean?
Somebody's got to do something.
You know what I mean?
If somebody fucking do something,
do they respond when you complain?
Somebody sent me a fucking email about a,
they returned something at best buy
and they charged him a 15% restock fee,
which basically they bought something.
It sucked. They brought it back.
Okay. If it costs a grand,
they charge them 150 bucks just
to put it back on the shelf.
So they still make money. So personally,
I'll never shop in a best buy again.
That's it. I'm done. That's what I'm
saying. That's just like, you know what,
I'm not eating fast food ever again, man.
So that basically means I'm not
fucking with best buy for three months.
I don't know. I'm sorry. I said, let's
get, let's get on with the questions.
Okay, this fucking, this podcast started
off really good and now it's just,
it's brining to a fucking halt. Let
me see if I can up the comedy here.
Take it up a notch. Okay.
This podcast is like,
it's like the Lakers in game
six. You know what I mean?
I never seen a team with west hard. Jesus
Christ. I'll fix her up by 40 points.
They're still shooting three pointers.
You think he would've put up with that?
Kareem, those guys would've been
throwing elbows. Larry Burton,
all of them would've been holding up the
trophy looking like Bobby Clark and the
Lakers just stood there
and watched it. All right.
Questions a number one. By the
way, I'm a Celtics fan and yes,
I am totally psyched and I'm sick.
All you like offense talking
to bite me about this,
buying them guy like he's the second
coming of fucking Bill Russell and Michael
Jordan. Okay. You guys need
to work on your heart first.
Why don't you draft a fucking heart first
and then talk to me about, you know,
fucking kid a coming off the goddamn
bench. Cause I don't give a fuck. Woo.
Got a little hostile there.
All right, question number one.
So when a comedian does the
comedy central presents,
is there an applause o meter?
Because sometimes it seems like an
odd place for an applause break.
Also. Is there an opening act to
warm up the crowd? Uh, let's see,
is there a plaza meter?
No, they just actually,
I think they just edit it in.
They'll take applause from a different
joke that really killed and uh,
I don't know,
maybe cause there's a low and for some
reason they think the viewer at home
isn't gonna notice or like when they cut
to somebody who's laughing hysterically
at another joke, that was hysterical.
That maybe even that didn't
even tell. They'll actually,
if they get a good laugh or in the
crowd, they use that as stock footage.
You know, Kinda like, you know, a
battle footage. You don't like the,
you don't want to show
the atom bomb. It's the,
they have like two or three views of that
stock footage of the fucking Adam Bond
. That's the same, it's the same
thing in standup comedy. Okay.
Some lady lost her shit laughing in
1983. You haven't ever noticed that.
Sometimes like they'll cut
to somebody. It's really bad.
Like on v t they'll cut to somebody
with a hairstyle that is just like from
fucking 20 years ago. You
know what I mean? Like,
remember black people used
to have the three levels,
like high top fade, like
three different levels.
So it was like a parking garage or like a,
some sort of fancy stairs
that would lead into like a,
a serving room or some shit. I
remember the, you know, during the, uh,
the Bobby Brown, uh, my
prerogative, that's what they'll do.
They'll show a guy,
black dude or a white dude or whatever
on comic view and he'll tell a fucking
joke, you know, that dress, you know,
they got a Obama and o a t
shirt, right? The comedian.
And then they'll cut to somebody who looks
like one of the guys and fucking boys
to men sworn like one of those lime
green fucking seven up sports coats.
Um, okay. Yeah, I think, I think I
overly explained that. Alright. Also,
is there an opening act to warm up
the crowd? Uh, if you're lucky? Yes,
there is. Uh, if there isn't, it sucks
because it's like nobody's laughing.
They're just sitting there and all of
a sudden you come out and you're just
like, what's up with lamps? These
things crazy and it's really shocking.
So hopefully there is a warmup act.
All my experiences there has been.
Okay. Question number two.
The question is why does asparagus
make your kiss stick? Um,
I just looked at, you said Piss, you know,
like they should have been the
f word in that sentence. Just,
just to prepare me for pis. I
should've been. Why does your,
why does asparagus make your
urine smell for a while?
Is fucking asparagus make you
pitch stick? You know what I mean?
You've got gotta be consistent
here. The first half,
you're like Dan rather reading off the
teleprompter and then you know the second
half you go and dice clay on me. All
right. Asparagus contains or this is,
this is the answer. I actually looked
it up. This was the first thing I saw.
So I'm going with this
like it's the truth.
Asparagus contains a sulfur
compound called Merck captain.
It's also found in rotten eggs,
onions, garlic and in this,
in the secretion of skunks, when
your digestive track breaks down,
this substance byproducts are
released. That caused the funny sense,
the funny scent. I don't think it's
funny you guys think it's funny.
It's actually kind of disgusting.
The process is so quick that your urine
can develop the distinctive smell within
15 to 30 minutes of eating asparagus.
She sources for more info. I left
that last part in there just in case.
I actually tried to play that
off like I wasn't reading it. Um,
so that's why it does it, you know,
cause there's some sort of sulfur compound
mercaptans that's also fun and rotten
eggs, onions, garlic and in the secretion
of skunks. You know what I mean?
That's just one of those bucket
things that the second you hear it,
just forget it. Okay.
Cause there's no way to say that at
a party and it's going to get you any
further with the person
you're talking to. You know,
either talking them into bed or trying
to get a promotion that's just like,
it just makes you weird.
And people just sorta rates raise their
eyebrows and nod and fucking walk away.
And you're left with a awkward silence.
And that's when you take out your cell
phone and you pretend you got to call.
You don't have a call. All
right, question number three. Oh,
this is a great question.
So who is more Badass?
Ty Domi above prober for those of
you who don't, uh, watch hockey,
these are two of the all time
great enforcers in NHL history.
Who's more Badass? This
is ty Domi or Bob Proberg.
It's not even a question. It's
fucking Bob Prober. Not In, not even,
I'm not even talking about at the height
of his career where he beats the shit
out of every tough guy and let me beat
the shit out of every tough guy in the
league. He didn't start losing
fights towards the end. Okay,
so everybody knows what he did on the
ice. This is what he did off the ice.
Here's a little blur by
finding him on the Internet.
Died a former NHL enforcement,
Bob pro truck, Bob Probert,
so I don't do the news. I can't
even read his back in jail.
He was arrested Friday night in Delray
beach after a scuffle with Florida police
that led to pro Bert being shocked
with the Taser Gun. This is,
this is what he's doing after his career,
when he's supposed to be
out on the golf course,
hanging out with Charles Barkley doing
cell phone commercial charged with
battery on a law enforcement officer
resisting arrest with violence and
disorderly conduct.
Trovert was held without bail at the
Palm Beach County jail while playing for
the Detroit Redwings in the eighties and
nineties propriate served a prison term
when he was caught trying to carry cocaine
into the United States from Canada.
He also had alcohol problems and was
charged with numerous driving expenses.
Provo probate was placed on inactive
status for the eighties 94 to 95 season
after he was involved in a motorcycle
accident and test showed alcohol and
cocaine in his system.
This is what he does off the ice is what
he was doing off ice during his career.
He probably had three fights that night.
Beat the shit out of a whole nother
team and that still wasn't enough.
He's like, Eh, you know, drink a 12
pack of fucking Schaffer, you know,
get an eight ball and
jump on a fucking Ninja.
They'll rate police officers first
spotted program at this. This is a,
this is for my July, June 4th, 2004 he's
well into his forties at this point.
All right.
They spotted him on Friday as he was
parked in his white BMW sport utility
vehicle,
the wrong way on a side street and
began hanging out his window to yell at
several men
before 1:00 AM and he was out
of his mind fucking pussy.
You know
[inaudible] you probably still wearing
the hockey gloves. I bet they're like,
he has to do that. He has,
he has to drop gloves before he
could fight or it's just like,
it's like no mark Nomar Garciaparra
before he hits, he's got a fucking,
you know, click his feet in his
shoes and justice gloves, you know,
his batting gloves or Betty.
He literally has to walk around
in hockey gloves or he won't,
he won't get the first couple
of shots off. So anyways,
for officers intervened when pro
Bert, a native of Windsor Ontario,
got out of the car and tried to start a
fight with one of the men according to
the report,
he then fought with the
officers and refused their
orders to drop to the ground.
As two of the officers
struggled to handcuff Filbert,
I'm opposite. Thomas Tolbert shot him
with a taser gun and he fell backwards.
But probate continued to resist their
efforts when they tried to handcuff them.
This is after getting tasered.
So Tolbert use the Taser gun to
stunt probate several more times.
Hey
is fucking unreal. The gun shoots Bob
probes. Yeah, that's that Bob. Why Shit?
I don't know if you guys know like it's
not like science fiction where they just
shoot electricity at you.
It shoots out these two
medieval fucking uh, inquisition
hooks in it hooks under your skin.
India chest like fucking eagle talents.
Like that's not enough to make you just
scream like a bitch and drop to the
ground. They then shoot electricity
into that. Okay. It's bad enough.
The guy's already fighting two
cops, you know, cops. Okay.
There's little cops like they
have like many UFC skills.
They all know armbars and choke holds
and they have guns and clubs and shit and
he's fighting two of them.
They still have to take them
two or three more times.
So I would go with Bob Prober.
I would say Bob Roberts a little
cuff and the tied to Omi. Okay.
Until Domi fights for fucking cops in
his mid forties and has to get Tabors
tasered numerous fucking times.
I'm going to go with Bob Prober and I
don't want have any sort of fucking hockey
geek. Come on here and talk to
me about fucking career stats.
Bring out dome use, arrest record.
All right. Has he been arrested?
I didn't even look it up. That's how
fucked up probate's arrest record was.
I didn't even have,
I didn't have the decency to look up
tied only so there you go. All right,
I've got to wrap this thing up
here. This is getting too long. Um,
there's a couple more questions.
I'll ask the answer real quick.
Have you ever done any work on
a cruise ship? Uh, yes I did.
And they won't be asking me
back. The captain wrote a letter,
said I was offensive to all races.
Said I made fun of Handicapped People
Cause I did a joke about midgets. Um,
you know, I don't, I don't know
what to tell you. You know, uh,
I was told that at the night. You
already answered this question.
Did I answer this question?
They told me he's going to be young people
and then I got on the cruise ship and
the first person I saw was that old
Vietnamese lady lady with no teeth asleep
with their mouth open. Wearing that
on picking rice hat. Then I tell you,
I told you that, right? I don't
fucking remember. All right,
let's get on with it. Okay.
That's the podcast for the week.
I'm going to tell you some
of my, uh, my fucking, uh,
my dates they have coming up here,
my slow computer, June, 2008.
Um, alright. Oh, big
date here. I've got, uh,
the Improv in Pittsburgh coming
up, uh, July 10th through the 13th.
Um,
I'm actually coming in town the day
before cause I'm going to be going to that
pirates game. So, uh, if
you go to the pirates game,
I'm sure you're going to be able to see
me cause it's gonna be me and 18 other
fucking people sitting out
there at the Goddamn game.
But that's, uh, July
10th through the 13th.
And then July 31st through August 3rd,
I'm going to be at the comedy. I'm sorry,
August 2nd. I'll be at the
comedy works in uh, Denver,
Colorado and uh,
August 14th to the 17th. I'll
be at the Improv in Miami.
Then I got a bunch of other dates coming
up cause right on the 23rd of August,
my uh,
my specialist coming out and then I'm
going to be doing a tour and information
will be coming out soon. All right,
so keep the questions coming. Uh,
let me know how you
guys think the story is.
Sometimes I think the stories are good.
Sometimes I think kind of slows
me down from a joking around.
I don't know if they're boring or if
they're interesting, please let me know.
Please give me your feedback.
I'll probably regret saying that cause
now I'm going to get a bunch of yeah and
you started too much during
them and blah blah blah. So
what, why would I open myself up to
more criticisms in life? Anyways,
thanks everybody. I really
appreciate all you guys listening.
I know I say I only have 14 listeners.
I know it's a lot more than that.
It's gotta be at least 32 at this point.
And I really appreciate that you guys
keep telling me that you like them.
As long as you're telling
me you keep liking them,
I'm going to keep doing
them and I feel like I'm me.
You don't have to fucking listen.
I don't know why I have this hippy
thing today. Uh, all right. That's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast.
God bless all of you and it's off
to Chicago and let's win there.
I'll talk to you guys. A, what
the fuck is it? Next Monday.
All right, happy July 4th
weekend. God bless America and uh,
you know, stop taking shit from American
Airlines and other airlines and stuff.
Taking shit from these corporations.
Go to their websites and complain.
Use a lot of words like
outrageous, ridiculous.
Try to go to a privately owned
shit. That's what I like doing.
I tried to do that. Then you go in
there and they shit all over the food,
all over the spoon. I mean,
this is food all over the spoon.
God just fucking, this is why, you know,
most people when they read the
dyslexic, I like to speak in dyslexia.
This is why I became a comedian.
If she ever fucking wondered
why this is why I did it,
because I'm too much of a moron to
exist in the real world. And secondly,
when I'm in the real world, um, I like,
I just keep hearing this voice
over and over and just going,
this is fucking stupid. This is
fucking stupid. Fucking stupid.
That's all I would hear. You know,
I tried to sit in the meetings as they
talked about how to make the product
better and to try and
increase the revenues.
And everyone was sitting there and they
had out little little notebooks cause it
was the 80s, early nineties and
it was fucking writing shit down.
And I just got so I couldn't hear what
the person was saying cause my brain just
kept going. This is fucking
stupid. This is fucking stupid.
I don't want to do this. I don't
wanna fucking do this. All right,
I don't fucking do this. Alright,
there you go. That's my job history.
Before I became a comedian.
It was me doing one job after another and
hearing a loud voice in my head going,
I don't want to fucking
do this, so I don't,
and now I do this and this is too long.
All right, I'll talk to you next week.
Have a great week. Bye.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] hey,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].